I'm curious about the music rights I
here Judas Priest playing in the
background for heavy metal parking lot
from what i've seen online music rights
is always a great for that it's the gray
area now I mean clearly you have to pay
if you want to have it commercially
released and have it you know with
anything you have to really cross the
t's and dot the i's I mean you're asking
for trouble when you don't do that but
since I've never when I do something
that is in the gray area that doesn't
you know do this i know from jump that
it's not commercially distributable and
I'm like if anything I'm doing now I
know if they're you know a lot of my
work can't be commercially distributed
but in some cases it can show on PBS
which is fine they're not paying for it
and its regional but you know every case
is different but the most the thing that
really you know or you can put it on on
you know TV in some fashion or certainly
put it online although they they're very
you know strict now about copy written
material on youtube and I'm sure other
portals as well and for good reason I
understand I think that's that's just
how it is you can somehow find ways to
leapfrog over that but even you're still
asking for trouble in the case of heavy
metal parking lot everything got cleared
everything got straightened out when we
went on the air I mean when we went on
TV at first though when it wasn't it was
just kind of given out we never had a
commercial plan for that it just kind of
unfolded and then when it was being sold
it was kind of on a very you know casual
underground basis through just you know
not major distributors no major
distributor you know would touch it
until it got cleared and that's all the
me know you but you know it but you can
find other alternative distribution and
you can find other ways to get it out
there whatever you have you know if
you're willing to take that risk and
that's something you have to you know
decide yourself as a filmmaker if you
want to take that risk and then
if something you know if it if you you
know have maybe a something come up
where there's a discrepancy you just
have to roll with it and perhaps stop
screening something so did they require
you to get errors in a mission well no
not who's they when all the distribution
deal what was already done I mean that
we didn't do we weren't involved with
that you know see that was it you know
wasn't the just everything was cleared
through the air when we had somebody
else clearing it and went on air went on
NBC so they showed it and they wrote the
check that I was not even privy to to
you know whoever had the music rights
but you know that allowed us to then
continue doing what we've been doing
with it which is just distributing it
very small scale and but still it's on
snagfilms and the DVD we have you know
which we made this was our 2006 20th
anniversary DVD soon to be obsolete as
deed the format you know goes away the
way of the eight-track but again errors
and omissions clearing music all that's
done the right way don't follow my lead
you know I'm a DIY filmmaker you have to
kind of just you know there's a place
for this and there's a you know
community of us out there and now
because there's so many ways to share
your work through these alternative
micro cinemas or venues cinefamily most
film festivals are you can will show
things that don't have everything
cleared because they can I mean they're
showing it for the distributors the
distributors will then try to maybe work
something out but I think if your idea
working in copy written material it's
just a set of challenges that you might
not have
you know the Constitution for I I've
kind of just built a body of work that
is comfortable in the you know in the
gray area that allows me to do my my
work in good faith and and realistically
knowing that I can't sell it but I can
share it if that makes sense it does
what are some things that other
filmmakers should be mindful of if they
want to entertain music even if someone
says oh don't worry I'll sign something
well I mean again it kind of depends on
what your level of your risk you know
comfort level is for me if it's minimal
then don't do what I do you know but I
feel like you know it's I'm making this
work I'm just compelled and interested
in making sometimes not all the time but
sometimes will borrow copy written
material or use copy written material
music what have you but you know there's
fair use issues that are prevalent you
can for documentary there's a whole fair
use movement which bears you no
discussion an exploration if you're a
filmmaker that has copy written content
in your your work but that's not for
television or for anything commercial
patently I mean that's for something if
it's a film I mean I don't even know the
I'm not an expert in fair use I just
know it's something that you can explore
exactly and like most of my work I don't
think would fall under fair use because
it depends on how much is you know
there's like hip-hop like rap like
sampling and hip-hop sampling this falls
into the same category you know it's
just because when it depends really on
who wants to challenge it I don't wanna
you know III don't know which way is
better or not i mean i think it's oh I
mean we for instance when we made neil
diamond parking lot we we were fortunate
to actually we
were in the New York underground film
festival and Neil Diamond's publicist
read about it and she came to the
screening you know and loved it but you
know and said I'll get this cleared for
you and so she helped us clear it for
festival rights you know I'm so those
kind of things can happen I mean stuff
was in that lucky break and and I think
we've you know just sometimes we've
managed to I mean I've looked I've hired
people in the Ernest Borgnine on the bus
we hire we cleared the rights for that
and I hired somebody to help do that but
ultimately you know it depends on what
your risk comfort level is and then how
much you want to be you know a DIY
filmmaker or one that's you know having
your work shown at landmark cinema so
you know I think there's there's good in
both
you